okay this is a story as much about
mental illness as it is about anything
else and we're not we're not ridiculing
mental illness we're not stigmatizing it
we're really talking about the sad state
of affairs in the united states where
there is so much undiagnosed and
untreated mental illness our friend
walter masterson was at the trump rally
in florence south carolina over the
weekend this is the rally we covered
live saturday and we had clips of
trump's speech from yesterday and we got
a little bit of insight into some of the
wackiest characters who were at the
rally yesterday but that was when they
were being interviewed by like
right-wing interviewers who didn't
really know the right questions to ask
walter actually knows what he's doing so
let's get right into this this is i i
believe
this is a clinically insane hypothesis
that this person has and if they were to
sit down with a psychiatrist i believe
they would be medicated for presenting
what this person presents in this video
take a look at this i got a good idea
what's going on in ukraine when they
went into ukraine and they found these
labs
they believed that made that the
deep state
is
possibly going to use a bio weapon on
russian people because they've been just
like they were collecting our dna in
china
they've been collecting their dna as
well okay so
chinese dna collection is analogous to
something that the deep state is going
to do
to then bio-weapon the russian
population
wow i mean
this is someone whose brain is
mayonnaise i i don't know any other way
to describe it so trump and putin right
now are the only ones successfully
fighting against the deep state i think
as well as chi too
oh xi jinping
so xi jinping is
fighting against the he's a good guy oh
oh he's fighting against no surprise by
the way that more of these trumpets just
love these dictatorial authoritarians i
could think about it he's not part of
the ccp secretly
[Applause]
xi jinping do you think he's working
with putin and trump against the deep
state i think he probably is yeah
probably i've heard that yeah i mean xi
jinping is working against the deep
state
in india yeah i've heard that xi jinping
modi
vladimir putin donald trump are all
working against the deep state right
those they love their dictators don't
they and you've got the white hat
alliance which is a lot of countries i
looked by the way for the white hat
alliance i i found no no record of it
there's a small hacking group called the
white hat alliance it's very clearly not
what this woman's referring to
uh france he is part of the good guys
the reason i think that is because he's
fixing to go into taiwan you wait and
see what i tell you when he gets into
taiwan guess what he's going to find
more labs more bio labs that is all
planned out y'all it's all planted this
is one big sting operation that's what i
believe yeah so xi jinping
putin and trump actually are the only
ones fighting uh against the deep state
and making sure that there are no bio
weapons that's right now if uh hold on
cause if they do not stop them they will
release them right um if if we were to
do a skit with some person joking about
crazy conspiracy theories
you couldn't do any better than that
their their mind is truly
gone or it was never there or whatever
uh here's another example and again
we're not joking when we say mental
illness but
but
we're also not saying
political extremism
is exclusively mental illness we're not
saying that either this just happens to
be the perfect nexus of both here's
another one when it came out it was
corona right
corona
corona is six letters
when you use gematria okay now
gematria is
hebrew numerology the aleph bet okay the
alphabet the hebrew alphabet the aleph
bet
uh it's the idea of assigning you know a
to a one to the letter aleph and okay so
so this is hebrew numerology you say a
is one b is two c is three right and you
put corona lined out at six six so
that's six six six but we found that out
so they're saying the white cr wing
crazies found it out so they changed it
to cover nineteen
which is c what is this c right
to c huh over look it up
ovid means sheep
19
military code for surrender
see
sheep
surrender
that's no joke wow that
so that's from the good liars these are
very sick people and my concerns are two
we should provide access to mental
health services it it i'm not joking
that is one side of this
the other side of this is
you don't
correct these views
by sitting down with people and chatting
for a few minutes okay so from an
electoral strategy
there's also a question as to what do
you do what do you do
and i don't have the answer but it's
very very sad what's going on
we have a situation right now where many
companies want and need to hire people
quickly
but it is difficult to find the right
candidates and workable is going to help
workable accelerates every step of your
hiring process
workable helps you cast the widest net
possible by posting your jobs to over
200 of the top job boards with just one
click it helps you evaluate and hire
quickly with modern tools like video
interviews and e-signatures you can
automate some of those repetitive tasks
like scheduling interviews whether
you're hiring for your coffee shop or
your engineering team workable is
exactly what you need to hire the right
people fast
start hiring today with a risk-free
15-day trial if you hire during the
trial which many do
it will cost you nothing just go to
workable.com
podcast to start hiring the link is down
below